♪♪♪
- With the second pick, the Denver
Broncos select...
- Super Bowl champion,
Super Bowl MVP...
- Von Miller.
♪♪♪
- Howdy, guys.
Welcome to this week's
Voncast. This is your host, Von Miller.
I'm live from Orchard Park in my office,
and you guys are watching on the Bleacher
Report app.
First and foremost,
I want to say thank you
to Bills Mafia, and the city of Orchard Park
and the city of Buffalo
for digging us out
and, you know, helping out and making
sure me and all of my teammates
made it to our game.
It was pretty crazy.
You know, we got 77 inches of snow.
And if you do the quick math,
that's about 6-foot-4.
You know, I was in Denver,
and I've seen snow before. And I've
been in snow. But six-and-a-half
feet of snow is just ridiculous.
And the only way
that we could have made it out was,
you know, a huge team effort and,
you know, huge effort from the community.
Lucky for me,
I live right next door to Coach McDermott.
So I just called Coach McDermott
the night before, and I said, "Hey,
whatever you doing tomorrow, I'm with you."
And he's like, "Hey, I'm gonna give you a,
I hit you up in the morning,
and I'll let you know
when I'm ready to go."
And I just knew I was cool, man.
And honestly,
when I moved here to Orchard Park,
I kind of felt like that was kind
of, like, my insurance policy.
I didn't think that
I would ever get
snowed in or anything like that.
But I knew if it were to snow,
if I ever needed a ride to work
or anything like that, then, you know,
I live right next door to Coach McDermott.
And the snow was crazy.
It just,
Lake Erie just dumped on us.
Snow after snow
after snow for a whole 24 hours.
And at first, I was kind of skeptical.
At first, I was kind of, you know, thinking
like, man, it might not snow like that.
It might, you know,
it might just do a little something.
But huge snowflakes, nonstop.
24 hours, man.
It was crazy, man. Lucky for me,
my son was here.
I live right next door to Coach McDermott.
We had plenty of food.
But that wasn't the case for everybody.
So I just want to say thank you to Orchard
Park.
Thank you to Bills Mafia.
You guys are incredible.
We had to reschedule our game.
And some people were saying that
the NFL has gotten soft;
they should've made us play
in the snow.
And I'm like, hey, I don't have a problem
playing in the snow,
but what about the safety concerns of fans
getting to and from the stadium?
You know,
people driving in the snow to and from?
That's all I was concerned about.
I wasn't really concerned
about playing in the snow.
I mean, football
is just one of those things where you just,
you just tough it out.
But it was just so crazy, man.
So we had to, you know, pack up
and really send our stuff to Detroit.
This is, I'm playing in Detroit two weeks
straight. Playing in Detroit on Sunday.
Then we've got a Thursday
night game with Detroit.
It's been a crazy couple of days,
but without any further ado,
let me get to this week's guest.
This is one of my guys, man.
This is one of my guys.
I've been knowing my guy for a long
time. Fellow Texas A&M Aggie.
Fellow
first-team All-American at Texas A&M.
He holds the record
for most receiving yards
in a single game and in a season.
He's a Super Bowl champion.
He's a four-time Pro Bowler.
He is the Bucs' all-time leader
in touchdowns and yards from scrimmage.
And I think you guys
can figure it out now.
It's my boy Mike Evans!
Mike, what's good, my boy?
- Just chillin' on the off day.
Thanks for having me, bro.
- Man, for sure, man.
As you probably heard, man, we got 77
inches of snow, and you're in Tampa.
I'm looking in the back.
The weather's nice.
- It was nice today.
- You just coming off a bye week.
What did you do for your bye week?
- Just went back to Galveston.
You know, the hometown. Chilled with the fam.
Did a couple community events.
And that's pretty much it, man.
And watched some football.
So it was a good week.
- Did you get a chance to play some golf?
- No golf.
- No golf?
- Man,
I've been playing golf for two years.
And I know we had that Texas A&M...
- Mmhmm.
- We had the Texas A&M alumni
golf tournament, and I saw you kind of
- Yep.
- get the bug, and like, you know, that was
dope to see, man.
Because I was in that same spot
just a year before, man.
You get out there with your boys,
and you start hitting the clubs and
hitting the balls. And then that
competitive nature just sets in, like,
- Mmhmm.
- nah, Imma figure this out, brah.
Imma figure it out.
It can't be that hard, man.
- And you can drink and play golf.
So that's pretty cool too.
- Bro, you can
drink, play golf.
You're out there for hours with your boys.
There's really nothing like it, man.
And I really just enjoy being outside.
I enjoy the companionship with my boys
and, you know, my family.
And it just gives you another thing
to have in common with your teammates.
- Mmhmm.
- It's just another thing that me
and my dad and me and my brothers can do.
And this is a game that we can play
for the rest of our lives.
You know, I started when I was 33.
And you can qualify for the senior tour at 50.
So that gives me 17 years to become a pro.
- How old are you right now?
- I'm 33.
33.
- OK.
- I'm 33 years old, so it gives me 17 years to get ready
for the senior tour.
And, you know, deep down—
- You still got it on that football field.
- I'm still trying, man. I'm still trying.
- Thirty-three's a young man.
You look like a young man out there.
- I think the key is once
you start saying, "I'm old," and once,
like, the everyday, like,
the everyday grind of football
and the things you do,
once you start telling yourself,
like, "Man, I'm getting tired of this."
Or, "Man, I'm getting old."
I think that's when you really become old
because your body is gonna do
what it's gonna do.
You really have no control over your body.
- Yeah.
- But your body is going to listen
to your mind too.
And once you start becoming old,
once your mindset becomes old,
like, it's just downhill from there.
I mean, you see Tom Brady do it, man.
- Oh, yeah.
- Like, you see him do it all the time.
He's not old mentally, bro.
Like, the body gonna do what it's gonna do.
But once you become old mentally, it's
not, you can't bounce back from that.
- And that's facts. I agree with that.
- Speaking of old, or time, you haven't
been playing wide receiver for a long time.
You played wide
receiver your senior year—
- Senior year in high school.
But look, people always think that.
But I have, I played when I was younger.
I just stopped playing
when I got to high school
cuz I wanted to focus on basketball.
And I've always loved
the game of football.
It's just, you know, when I got
to high school, I got a little taller.
Basketball is my favorite sport.
I just wanted to focus on that.
My senior year,
I just didn't want to be bored in school,
and my friends knew I could play.
So they were like,
"Senior year, you got to come out and play."
I went out and played, and it
was one of the best decisions I ever made.
- Man, for sure, man.
You continue to kill stuff.
And I know
we're talking about killing stuff, man.
You're chasing history right now, man.
You 329 yards away from a thousand yards,
which would be your ninth
consecutive season doing that. That would
break your own record of eight seasons.
You knew that?
Of course you know that, man.
- Yeah.
- Did you know—
did you know you're 28 yards away from 10,000 yards?
10,000 career yards?
- Yeah, I knew that too.
There's something records—
- Did you know—
- I'm not aware of, but those records I'm aware of cuz
you know, that's a
that's a pretty cool feat.
And hopefully I can get it.
You know, one catch. That'll be cool.
I wanted to do it at home.
- Yeah, you're at home this weekend coming up.
Bro, did
you know you're 88 yards away
from passing Shannon Sharpe
for 50th all time in career receiving yards?
- Uncle Shay Shay?
- Yeah, Uncle Shay Shay, man. You
88 yards away.
- Shoutout to Uncle Shannon.
I got to catch you.
- How do you be so consistent, man?
Like, what,
talk to me about, like, being consistent.
- You know how it is. You're consistent too.
- I know, I know. I want to
get it from, like, Mike Evans.
- From me?
- You know, I don't play offense.
Yeah. I want to see how, like,
- Yeah.
- what is your mindset?
How do you, what is the,
not necessarily secret,
but how do you do it, bro?
- I mean, it's a lot of things combined.
You know, I've been blessed
with this ability, and this size
and this competitiveness.
Because I love the game of football,
and you gotta have guys believe in you.
So, quarterbacks have to believe in you,
the offensive coordinator.
And you've got to take care of your body.
I feel like each year throughout my career
I've learned how to take care of my
body better and better.
- Mmhmm.
- So that's been a plus for me. And,
you know, just practice. You know how
it is. The game slows down each year.
- Yeah.
- And that's just what's been happening. And
I've just been blessed to be in this position.
And so Imma take full advantage of it
and have fun as long as possible.
You know, give it my all.
- That's dope to hear, bro, because,
you know, people ask me all the time, like
"Von, like, when you gonna hang it up?
When you gonna do—"
I'm like, bro, I, it was days
and it was nights that I
got on my hands and knees
at the end of my bed, and I prayed like:
"Lord, please
let me go out here and have a good game.
Let me get a scholarship.
Let me ball out in this bowl game.
I hope I get drafted."
Like, these are talks
that I have with God, right?
And, you know, to look back on it
12 years in, like, I just don't want to, like,
give that gift away.
I want to, I don't even want to say use it
all up.
But I want to fulfill,
I really want to take full advantage
of the talent
and the gift that God gave me.
And I just want to keep going
until he says I can't go.
Like, I've already played 12 years
and won two Super Bowls.
Like, it's easy to, like, get complacent,
you know, as you know.
But for me, I'm just not satisfied,
bro.
I just want to keep going
as long as I possibly can go.
And it's not for anybody else.
It's for me.
You know, when you start having kids
and stuff, you like,
you want them to be able to look at you
and what you do in your career.
You want them to, like, lean on
some of the things that you did.
And I want to be able to tell them
like, man,
I left it all out there, and I
did everything that I possibly could do
to provide for you guys
and to take full advantage of the gift
that God gave me.
Cuz there's a lot of people
that I played with
that was better than me, faster
than me, stronger than me.
All of these things.
But they're not here right now, and I am.
And I want to take full advantage of
of this opportunity,
man. And when you get to, like, Year 12,
I'm sure you do the same thing.
You start thinking about legacy and like:
What do you want your legacy to be?
And for me, I just want to win
as many championships as I possibly can.
I really don't care
what people think about me
as far as, like, the outside world.
But I do care about what
my teammates think about me.
And the people that really know me,
I care about what they say about me
when I'm not in the room.
And those are two things
that I care about.
I want to win as much as I can,
and I want to get as many sacks
as I possibly can.
And I
care about what my teammates, the guys
that I spend most of my time with,
you know, 80 percent of my time with,
I care about what they say about me, man.
And what do you
want your
legacy to be?
I know you think about it, man.
Like, do you have an idea
or—what do you want your legacy to be?
- I couldn't have put it any better.
Like, what you just said is like,
you know, what
I think all the time and how I feel
about being in this situation.
But that's why, you know, you're great.
You know,
the greats have that type of mindset.
They want to keep going
as long as they can.
They don't want to, you know, give that gift
away, like you said.
So, you know, I feel the same way, bro.
Like, God blessed me with this talent
and to be in this position.
So I'm just taking full advantage.
- Definitely.
- And keep having fun while I do it.
Cuz, you know, you can get down.
You know, there's times
you get embarrassed out here
and things like that. You get injured.
But it's like, we dream
to be in this position for so long.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, I'm
not going to let a couple of plays here
and there, like, deter my confidence
in, you know, my legacy
and, you know, how I feel about the game.
So, you know, I just try to be as positive as
I can as much as possible.
- For sure, man.
And, you know, coaches always say—
not only coaches, but, you know, people
that really observe the game and,
you know, the
players that have come before me, man—
they tell you, like, playing in the NFL
is only a short piece of your life, like.
So while I'm here in this
short moment of my life.
You know, this, whatever 20,
22 years or however long I play,
I want to take full advantage of that.
Like, I want to take full...
- You going for 20?
- I'm going for 20.
You know, I'm aiming high. I'm going for 20.
Bruce Smith, he played for 19 years,
and he had 200 sacks.
- He's the all-time sack leader.
- All-time sack leader at 200.
He played 19 years.
So in my head, like, if I can play 20 years
and I can average 10 sacks—
- And he played in Buffalo.
That's pretty cool.
- Yeah, he played
in Buffalo, man.
He's come to my pass-rush summit. He's
one of the biggest reasons
why I came here.
You know,
I talked to him, and he was like: "Hey,
you gonna be in the cold. Like, offensive linemen,
they're not going to want to get out of
their stance.
You're going to be able
to get a jump on the ball.
Josh Allen, they're going to score points."
You know, all of these things, man.
And that was my, I would say
that, like, that's my OG or my vet.
And you have a vet too. You have an OG too that's
throwing you the ball every day, man.
Tom Brady, man.
I'm such a huge fan of Tom Brady
and what he's done on and off the football
field, man.
And I actually think that
the NFL is better when Tom Brady wins.
Like, when he wins, like.
- I think it is when I'm on his team for sure.
- Yeah, for sure.
For sure, man.
The atmosphere is just,
the atmosphere around
the NFL is just great, man.
And so, I know y'all been struggling.
Y'all been struggling,
you know, to start the season.
But, you know, he's turning it around, bro.
He's still Tom Brady, man.
- Mmhmm.
- And I'm a huge fan of Tom Brady.
I'm a huge fan of you, man.
How has he changed the way
that you play
or that you prepare for games?
- He's so detailed.
He's the most detailed player
I've ever played with.
So he makes sure that we're all on point
and ready.
So, since I've been playing with him,
my mental errors have been way lower.
You know, obviously everybody still makes
mistakes. But, like, our team as a whole, like,
our mental errors go way down.
And that's going to be, you know, cause
for more success on your team,
when guys are doing the right things
in the right spots,
especially with the talents we have.
So, you know, I'm just more
detailed going into the game
and knowing the assignments
and the coverages and things like that.
And taking care
of my body is the main thing I've learned,
you know, the last three years
I've been playing with him.
He's always getting treatment
throughout the day. Always.
- Bro, it's a 24-hour thing.
Like, it's, you have to always,
there is no—when you're a professional athlete,
there is no down time or no chill time.
So I spend more time
trying to get my body ready to go or doing,
it can be as simple as NormaTec
or ice tub.
- Mmhmm.
- I spend most of my day, like, doing that
stuff. Not necessarily practicing or in a
film room or anything like that.
I spend most of my time just getting ready
to play in another football game.
- Yep. You put the time
in, you'll get the results.
- Yeah, for sure.
I got so many Tom Brady stories, man.
And I've been in the league
12 years. I've been around Tom.
I started to really
love Tom when I got to kick it with him
outside of, like, on the football field.
I was in the Kentucky...
I went to the Kentucky Derby,
and they had me as a color commentator,
a lifestyle correspondent
at the Kentucky Derby, NBC.
And they were telling me like, "Hey,
can I get an interview with Tom?"
Like, could I interview Tom.
And I was like, man, y'all
just let him chill, man.
Y'all just let him chill.
And they was like:
"He never does any interview, man.
If you can do that, man, it'd be great."
And I'm like, man, like
I know Tom. I'm gonna go
over there and gonna ask him, man. And I ask him,
and he was like, "Yeah, sure, let's do it."
And everybody from NBC just, like, lit up.
They was like,
"Bro, is he, bro, he's getting it, he—"
And it was, like, live.
And it was, like, right here and right now.
And like, of course, you know,
we had had a couple of drinks, man.
It was like this dope moment on
national television at the Kentucky Derby.
We had our hats on, and he wasn't like—
I was asking him questions.
He was giving them back.
It wasn't, like, me putting a mic up to him
and, like, just one-sided, bro.
Like, he was into it.
I was into it, man. And,
you know, he didn't have to do that.
And he did it for free, man.
And he had to do none of that, man.
And I kicked it with him
after. It was him and Julian Edelman.
I think Garoppolo
and all the guys.
I went out to, like, a couple of parties
with those guys, man.
I'm like, bro, like, Tom kick it like
how I kick it.
- Mmhmm.
- I was like, they kick it how I kick it, man.
And, you know, I had got his number,
and I had to do the pass-rush summit
later. And I had did, like, a virtual pass-rush summit.
And he was gonna be, like, a
guest on the pass-rush summit.
Like, our quarterback correspondent.
It was supposed to be, like, a surprise
cuz I had, like, 5,000 people
virtual for the pass-rush summit.
And I was supposed to surprise them with Tom Brady.
The schedules didn't work out,
but I still got a chance to talk to Tom
Brady after by the pass-rush summit.
I asked him for a jersey.
And I didn't even have to ask him
five or six times. I asked him for a jersey
one time. Boom, that mother
was there, like, in two, three days, bro. Like,
I didn't have to remind him, none of that.
None of that stuff, bro.
And, you know, I ran into him, like, at UCLA
after he got done throwing, bro.
And I just come to the conclusion,
like, anybody that doesn't like Tom Brady,
they just simply don't like winning, bro.
And that's not a good reason
to not like somebody because they win,
and they're not successful.
Bro, do you have, like, a good Tom
Brady story
that you could tell us? That you want to
tell us?
- I got so many great ones.
He's such a down-to-earth guy.
Like you said. Like, growing up,
I didn't like him when I was a kid cuz
I was a Peyton Manning fan.
Most people know that by now.
But, you know, when you're a kid,
you're a little naive.
You don't really understand.
But, you know, definitely when I went
to high school and college,
you know,
I definitely respected his greatness.
But when I met him,
he was such a down-to-earth guy.
He loves his kids. He's a great father.
And I have a lot of great stories
with him.
You know, I've been with him
for the past three years.
One cool thing we did,
we went to the, right
after Kobe, when everything
was starting to open back up,
the UFC had an event in Jacksonville.
And Usman
and Masvidal fought for the second time,
and Tom hooked it up.
He got us backstage to meet Dana White,
the president.
We met a lot of a lot of people
back there, and I'm a huge fight fan.
So to be that close and personal, and he
just, he hooked it up like it was nothing.
We had a great time.
And, you know, that's it. Obviously,
the Super Bowl parade was lit.
- It was lit, man.
- I mean, everybody was having a great time.
Hopefully we do that again.
I know y'all trying to have y'all own
parade.
But we finna get hot,
I feel like.
- I don't know, man.
I mean,
I want you to have a lot of success, man,
and win a lot of games. It's just
one game.
You know, if we play y'all, man,
you know, I got to
get mine too, man.
What was, you know, you say, Tom
Brady is a such a down-to-earth guy, man.
What was his reaction when you gave
his 600th career touchdown ball to a fan?
Well, during the game, he came up to me.
Well, he was like, good catch and all that.
And I said, I apologize.
Do you want me to
to get the ball back for you?
And then he was like, nah, you good, bay.
And then, you know, luckily,
our guy Tim Jarocki
got it back for us.
But he handled it cool.
He handled it cool.
I didn't know it was his, you know,
to my defense, I didn't know.
- You just thought it was—
- I'm just happy I scored a touchdown.
And it was something I've done before
Tom came to our team.
So, I just used to give a ball to the fans
in the stands if I scored a touch.
But he handled it cool.
We got it back for him too, so.
- Of course he did, man.
That's Tom Brady, man. He's a cool quarterback, man.
Speaking of cool quarterbacks...
- That's Tim Jarocki right there.
- The other guy right there?
- That's my guy.
- Oh, him with the hat? Him with the hat on.
Shoutout Tim, man.
- He got it back.
- Shoutout Tim, man.
- And I think that that guy's name is Byron
that gave the ball back, so, appreciate you.
- Yeah, they had to hook him up too,
though, for sure.
You know, Tom is a cool quarterback, man.
And speaking of cool
quarterbacks, man. You played with another
one of my favorite quarterbacks, man.
Johnny Manziel, man.
- He the man.
- I love Johnny, man.
I love Johnny, man. That's my guy, man.
I didn't get a chance to play with Johnny
in all of my time—
- I know. I wish we got to play
with you, man.
That would have been so dope.
- Bro, me, you,
- We won the natty.
- man, Johnny, man.
It just would have been crazy,
man. Like, man.
And
I was in the league, and just, College Station
just changed when Johnny got there.
- Yeah.
- Like, it just totally changed.
Like, he brought, like, such a different light
upon College Station and Texas A&M.
And I think still to this day, they
still are, like, living
from the light and exposure that Johnny
put on that, on our franchise, man.
Like, he
definitely touched our franchise,
and he only played there two years, right?
- Two years, yeah.
- He only played two full seasons
and he was a redshirt before.
- We came in together. Yep.
- Yeah, he wasn't even there
that long, man.
And I didn't get to play
or be a teammate with Johnny.
You know,
the Aggie network is just so strong, man.
And I got to kick it
with Johnny off the football field,
and I got to, you know, know him as a person, man.
And that's like, that's my guy, man.
Talk about some of the, you know, talk about
your time playing with him at Texas A&M.
Y'all won a lot of big games.
Beat Alabama. Like, how was playing
with Johnny, man, at Texas A&M?
- He was unbelievable.
Well, right away, you know,
we redshirted in 2011.
We came in together, and just right away,
I knew he was different.
Cuz he could, he was a freak athlete.
You know, he could hoop. Played baseball,
and he could make all the throws
on the run and in the pocket.
You know, he was a little smaller
quarterback, but,
you know, he used to give our defense fits.
Our first-team defense.
Me and him would be on a scout team.
They'd make Johnny Manziel go live.
And he'd just be all over the field,
just making plays.
And he just was different.
And he made it look so easy out there.
He just was
always confident going into every game,
and it was just fun to, you know, play with him
for those two years
and, you know,
change the culture down there in Aggie land.
- So, the biggest game that I played
in, I would say I played in three
games that were huge, man.
My senior year...
- Nebraska?
- Would be Nebraska. Six,
I think we beat them 6 to 3
or 9 to 6 or something like that.
No touchdowns were scored.
It was a nationally televised game.
They were ranked. I think they were Top 10
or something like that.
We beat them. OU at home.
We beat those guys too.
That was a huge game for us.
We were supposed to lose that game
by so much. Had some goal-line stops.
And of course,
whenever you can beat Texas. Beat Texas
my senior year.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, that was a huge win too, man.
What were some of the biggest—
- Cyrus Gray had a big game.
- He had a huge, I think he went for 200 yards,
man.
- Huge game. Mmhmm.
- What's, like, your top three games
as an Aggie?
Of course, that Alabama game will be one.
-  Bama, when we beat 'em,
obviously, was No. 1.
Even though I didn't have a good game,
you know. Although the second
half of my redshirt freshman year, 2012,
which was our best team,
I was
hurt. Like, I had a strained hamstring,
and I was just playing through it.
I couldn't really run go routes.
I was just running stop routes and slants
and stuff like that.
Big bodying. You know, back-shoulder fades.
But it was working.
I don't know how I was able to do that,
but you know, that game,
the Alabama game was No. 1. In 2012,
we beat them. LA Tech.
We played LA Tech short-handed.
We were winning 34 to 7, I think, at halftime,
and they came all the way back.
They were ranked, like, 23rd,
and we were Top 20 as well.
And they came all the way back
and tied the game up at the end.
And then Johnny, like,
had one of his best games. Think he had,
like, close to 200 rushing yards,
300 passing yards.
Know I had a couple of big plays
that game.
So that was definitely one of them.
And we beat Oklahoma in the Cotton Bowl.
- For sure.
- That was fun.
It was a really fun game.
- At AT&T Stadium, Cowboys Stadium, man.
That was a huge one, man.
I check in on the Aggies,
man, and I watch the Aggies, man.
And, you know,
we had the best recruiting class
in the history of college football
last year with 13 5-star recruits.
We got Jimbo Fisher.
We got the best facilities in the world.
Now, it's not a recruiting pitch for anybody
that's listening.
I'm just saying, like, bro,
we have the best of the best, man.
And, you know, we got a video of a half-empty
stadium from this last place.
Have you seen that video?
- I haven't, but I heard about it.
Our game's
never like that, no matter what.
Like, Aggie fans don't do that.
OK, I see it.
- Man,
I have never seen the stadium like that.
- Did we play UMass?
Who'd we play? UMass?
- I think it might be a combination of,
you know, how we've been playing this year.
- The weather?
Was the weather bad?
- The weather.
The weather was bad.
- The team.
- And the team that we were playing.
I think it was just
a combination of everything.
But, like you said, bro, I've never seen it the stadium
like that.
- No, I've never seen that.
That's not even a spring game, like.
- No. Spring games
don't even look like that.
What do we need to do to get our team
back on track?
- It starts with the quarterback position.
Always,
I feel like. I mean, we've got to get,
find the right guy at quarterback.
We've got to build trust around him.
Got to establish a good running game.
I mean, we've got the talent
to compete.
I really don't know.
Like, I haven't been around the place as much,
so I don't know.
- Man, like...
- You don't think quarterback No. 1?
We have to find the right guy
at quarterback.
- You know, like,
you might not know this about me, but
when I'm done playing football,
like, one of my dreams is to be a GM.
I've been around some great ones,
so I kind of look at football and college
football from a different lens.
And, you know,
I like our quarterbacks.
I like quarterbacks that
have been the guys in high school,
that were ranked in high school.
I think,
I don't think it's Coach Fisher.
You know, that's not, I think in college
you always, you get to a point
where it's like fire the coach.
- It's hard to put another coach in.
Like, yeah. You can't do that every time.
- No, it ain't Jimbo's fault.
You really just got to wash
this season away, and next year,
we have to come with it.
These 13 5-stars that we had,
they'll be sophomores next year.
And now, if we don't have success
next year,
then you, now
you've got to start pointing the finger.
And in college football, it always—
- You can start pointing it a little bit more,
but we definitely got to give them time.
- Yeah.
- We've got a really young team.
And football is hard as hell.
- It's hard.
- Especially the SEC.
- The SEC!
- That's like the second-highest level in the world.
- Bro, we...
- It's tough.
- But you know how the Aggies, they
got to,
we got to win, and we got to win now.
Especially after, you know, 13 5-stars
that we've got.
- A lot of money. A lot of
money is going into the,
you know, the football team, so
we gotta make it work.
- All of these facilities
and everything that we got, man.
But, you know, I think we got the talent.
I think we'll be able to turn it around.
And, you know, the GM in me.
The GM in me, right.
Looking at these college players
and looking forward to what I want to do
now. I've got a game that I want to play with you.
It's called the Cheat Code.
We've already
established, like, you're a cheat code. You know,
I've seen you play.
I've seen you game and stuff too.
I don't know if you're hacking.
You're probably hacking in real life too
cuz you code in real life,
you code on the game.
Imma show you four offensive
lineups, and you can tell me
which one is breaking
the most scoring records.
And, you know, I got you in all of 'em,
of course.
I just want to see what lineups do
you think? I want to sharpen my GM skills.
- All right.
- And I'm always a fan of iron sharpens
iron. You know, you're iron. I'm iron.
- Let's do it.
- I just want to see. I just want to see
if I'm right, man.
Let's see offense No. 1.
Offense
No. 1 is Lamar Jackson,
Mike Evans, Travis Kelce,
Derrick Henry and David Bakhtiari.
- Lamar Jackson's
one of the most electrifying players,
you know, in the history of football.
Derrick Henry is one of the best
running backs in the history of football.
Travis Kelce is one of the best tight ends in history,
And Dave is an unbelievable left tackle.
He's probably one of the best too in history.
So, I mean, this is going to be, this is
gonna be too hard to choose.
Everybody's going to be great.
- I think this offense—
- But I love offense No. 1.
- I think this offense would be more run-oriented.
And I think the dynamic that Lamar Jackson
and Travis Kelce
will have will kind of
be like Patrick Mahomes and Travis Kelce.
You know, Lamar is going to be running
all over the place.
- Mmhmm. Yeah, Lamar loves his tight ends.
He likes Andrews. Mmhmm.
- He's going to hit you.
He's going to hit Travis Kelce.
You know, I think this is going to be more
of a running type of offense.
Of course, we got David.
We got Bakhtiari up top.
He's going to be able to block it up
before the pass is up the field.
I like that lineup.
But here's offense
No. 2: We got Josh Allen,
Mike Evans, Justin Jefferson,
Trent Williams and Lane Johnson.
What do you like about this lineup?
- I love this one.
Two receivers. We going to throw the ball
a lot.
Like you said, offense
one is going to be run-heavy.
Offense two, Josh likes to sling the rock.
Me. J Jets. Big Trent, one
the best O-tackles of all time. Big Lane as well.
I mean, I love offense No. 2.
A lot of targets.
- Offense No. 2. Offense No. 2 is gonna
pass the shit out of the ball.
I tell you that right now.
You got one of the best, the best left
tackle in the league, and you got the best
right tackle in the league.
And of course, you know, one and two,
they can go back and forth, you know,
but you got two of the best
offensive linemen
in the league, two of the best wide
receivers in the league. No. 1
and No. 2.
And if it is not No. 1 and No. 2,
it's 2 and 1. Like, you know how it is.
It just goes up and down
- Mmhmm.
- each and every week.
And then we got the best quarterback.
I know you will say differently.
But, you know, you got Tom Brady, I know,
but.
- He's definitely—
Josh is definitely one of them, though.
- Josh Allen.
I like—I really like offense No. 2.
I like offense No. 2 a little bit
better than I like offense No. 1.
And it's not an indictment on anybody.
- It’s just there’s a running back in the first one. And there's no running back in this one.
- Yeah. Hell yeah. It's not an indictment on anybody.
I'm just, you know,
we just playing a game right here.
And this is offense No. 3, right?
So, let me show you offense No. 3.
We got Patrick Mahomes,
Mike Evans, A.J. Brown,
Quenton Nelson and Saquon Barkley.
Whatchu like about that one?
- I love Pat Mahomes. Like,
I'm a huge Pat
Mahomes fan. A.J. Brown is doing his thing.
Quenton Nelson is a beast. And Saquon’s
a beast, and he needs to get paid.
I love this offense, too.
- Yeah. This is gonna be a little bit more—
- They’re all pretty close right now.
All these offenses are really close
right now.
- It's gonna be a little bit more—
it's gonna be dynamic too.
- Me and A.J., we're really physical receivers,
so that's, like, two really
physical receivers out there with—Quenton
Nelson is one of the most physical guards
in the league. And Saquon.
And Pat can make plays out of the pocket,
in the pocket,
he can throw it off his back foot 70 yards.
- Just think about—
- That’s a scary offense right there.
- Just think about this whole offense
coached by Andy Reid in Kansas City.
Like, that would be crazy with drawing
up the plays—
- Oh, we throwing coaches in there too, hmm?
- Nah, we not throwing coaches.
We not throwing coaches.
I'm just imagining. I'm
just imagining, like, Saquon—
- Nah. That’s a great offense.
- Saquon with Andy Reid and Patrick Mahomes
and you and A.J. Brown, and Quenton Nelson
blocking up front. Like, this’ll be scary, too.
And this is my last one right here.
- Absolutely.
- This is my last one right here.
Offense No. 4.
We got Kirk Cousins,
Mike Evans, Tyreek Hill,
George Kittle and Nick Chubb.
- Mmm. Mmm.
Sheesh. “You like that?!”
Kirk did that against us. Our team. In 2015.
That was us. The Buccaneers. We was
beating them, like, by three scores, I think.
And they came back and beat us.
- Damn.
- So, you know, shout-out Kirk, man.
He's always had swag.
- I love Kirk.
- He's a really smart quarterback.
Good ball placement.
He's very underrated.
I like Kirk a lot. Cheetah. Man,
he's doing his thing no matter who
the quarterback is.
The system doesn't matter.
He's one of the best players, one
of the best weapons in NFL history. Man,
he's doing his thing.
The fastest player I
ever seen with my own two eyes.
Like, he's so fast, so good.
George Kittle.
Pass game, run game,
he can do it all.
- Yeah.
- Nick Chubb is one of the toughest runners
in the league.
- Yup.
- We play them next week.
Y’all just played them.
I mean,
- Yup.
- all these offenses are scary.
I don't know which one.
I got to see them all again,
but—
- That crazy, man. I love Nick Chubb.
I love George Kittle, Tyreek Hill.
That's my boy, Kirk Cousins.
I was trying to get him
to come to the Denver Broncos
when he was getting ready to leave
the Commanders.
And I love Mike Evans, of course,
but which—I'm gonna run through them
one more time, and you tell me which one.
Let's go back to offense No. 1.
We can meet the offense
No. 1 guy.
- One was Lamar Jackson.
- Lamar Jackson.
- Me, Derrick Henry. Oh, there you go.
T. Kelce.
- One was Lamar
Jackson, Travis Kelce, Derrick Henry,
Bakhtiari.
Offense
No. 2, we got Josh Allen,
Mike Evans, Justin
Jefferson, Trent Williams, Lane Johnson.
Offense No. 3,
we got Patrick Mahomes,
Mike Evans, A.J. Brown, Quenton Nelson,
Saquon Barkley.
I love all these guys, by the way.
Like, this is not an indictment on anybody.
- Yeah, I love them all as well.
- And then No. 4, we got Kirk Cousins,
Mike Evans, Tyreek Hill,
George Kittle and Nick Chubb.
I'll go first. Me,
from seeing it from—
- You go first then.
- Me seeing it from a pass-rush point of view,
me seeing it from the type of headaches
that it would give on everybody,
I got to go with offense No. 2.
I got to go with
offense No. 2.
Josh Allen. Of course, Trent Williams
and Lane Johnson on the same team.
Oh, my God.
And you got Mike Evans
and Justin Jefferson? Who [stammering incredulously]—
And then you got Josh Allen?
Like, what—what?
People would lose sleep over this offense.
People would lose sleep
over this offense for sure.
Which one you got, man?
If you had to pick one,
which one would you pick?
- It's a close call.
I'mma go offense No. 3. Is that
Pat, me, A.J.?
- That’s—yeah. That’s Pat, you, A.J., Quenton Nelson and Saquon.
- Saquon.
- Yup. It's not an indictment on—
- Yeah, I’m going there.
- It's not an indictment on nobody, man.
- Nah. I love them all. But Pat, A.J.
- All of these players
are Hall of Fame players, man.
- I don't know.
It was—that's close.
I really want to pick ‘em all. But I guess—
- I have a show.
- I’ll just pick three. Cuz
Pat's from Texas.
- Yup. I love Pat.
- And A.J. Brown, SEC.
And I love Saquon and Quenton Nelson,
so I’ll go with them.
- Yeah. They say offense
No. 3 is getting a lot of love in
the chat.
I love, man, I love Patrick Mahomes.
Like, I love Tom Brady too.
I love Tom Brady. I love Patrick Mahomes.
You know, the crazy thing is I
almost got a Tom Brady tattoo
and a Peyton Manning tattoo.
Those are my two favorite quarterbacks ever.
And it wasn't going to say
“Tom Brady,” of course, or, like, “Peyton Manning.”
- You like both? Like, growing up,
or when you got to the league
cuz...
- I've been a Brady fan—
- You gotta like one or the other.
- No. I've been a Brady fan forever, but I played
with Peyton Manning, so I got to see—
- So, that's when it happened? OK.
- I got to see Peyton Manning,
like, up close and personal,
and I got to see what made him great.
I got to experience and witness greatness,
like, up close. Like, he has such—
he had, the way he went about his business
and the things that he did with
his teammates and the way he, the way he led,
it had such a huge impact on me
and my career and how I lead today
and how I interact with my teammates.
So, I love Tom Brady,
but I witnessed Peyton Manning,
so I was gonna get like the Peyton
Manning “18” in Broncos font.
I was just gonna get the Broncos font “18.”
Then I was gonna get the Patriots,
like, font, like, “12” on my ankle.
But last-minute I decided to change it. You know, tattoos hurt.
So, I was like, “Man,
I'mma just figure another space,
I’mma figure another space for this.”
I'm glad I did, man.
But I love these guys, though, man.
I really do, man.
I got somebody in the chat, they
asking me about Harry Potter.
- My favorite.
- Whatchu you like about Harry Potter?
- I grew up on Harry Potter, man.
Second grade,
my teacher, Mrs. Jones, read us the book.
And then that same year,
the first movie came out, “Sorcerer's Stone.”
And I went to see it,
and I fell in love with the movies.
I love everything about it.
You know, Harry's
the chosen one from birth.
Like,
I don't know if you know much about it,
but all the odds are stacked against Harry.
Like, he lives with his human aunt and uncle
and cousin.
They do him dirty.
You know, he's an orphan, and he,
he's just the chosen one.
And, like, the friendships in it,
the way that they all grew together—
if you haven't seen the Harry Potters,
I suggest you watch them,
especially if you got young children.
- Yeah, of course, man.
You got a Harry Potter tattoo.
- Oh, yeah.
- That's icy too.
- I just got a little more.
I got the Hogwarts
castle behind that during the bye week.
So, that's one thing I did during the bye week.
Added a little more.
- If we had to choose a house for you—
what is it,
Hufflepuff, Slytherin or Gryffindor—
which one would you be?
- It say it right there: Gryffindor.
- What is that? Gryffindor?
- Yup.
- “Mike Evans is totally a Gryffindor.”
- I’m Gryffindor. Harry's
Gryffindor. Ron. Hermione.
It’s all my favorite characters.
- I got some other guys in the NFL.
Let's put them in Hogwarts houses as well.
- In—OK.
-Whatchu think about Tom Brady?
What house would he be in?
- Slytherin.
Slytherin.
- Him in
Slytherin?
What about what about my guy,
Jalen Ramsey?
- Slytherin.
- Slytherin?
We got Aaron Rodgers.
- But look: Slytherins are, they're talented,
you know, but they're like—
- Yeah. Yeah.
- they're a little more, like, you know, savage—
- Yeah, edgy.
- than all the other houses. Yeah.
- Yeah. I know. I know a little bit about,
I know a little bit about Harry Potter, man.
- All right. All right. My bad. Just I wanted to explain.
- I'd probably be Slytherin as well.
I’d probably be Slytherin as well too, man.
That's just me.
I, you know, you got to have that edge, man.
You got to have that edge to
rush the passer, man. You know,
you can make alliances and be cool and,
you know, get stuff
done at the end of the day.
But you just gotta,
you just gotta have that dog
in you, man.
I got some more guys on here.
Whatchu think about Aaron Rodgers?
- Let me see. He's like a Cedric Diggory type,
so Hufflepuff.
- Hufflepuff?
- Hufflepuff.
- Rob Gronkowski.
- Oh, Gronk's going to Gryffindor with me.
He's Gryffindor?
- Yeah, he's Gryffindor.
- All right. The Kelce brothers.
- They’re similar.
We’re gonna put them in, uh, Gryffindor.
- Gryffindors too?
Jameis Winston.
- Gryffindor.
Ravenclaw.
- Ravenclaw?
Kirk Cousins.
- Hufflepuff.
- Hufflepuff for sure.
- Yeah.
- Russell Wilson.
- Ravenclaw.
- Ravenclaw?
Justin Jefferson.
J. Jets?
Slytherin or Gryffindor. I’ll go Slytherin.
- And I got, I got one more:
Marshon Lattimore.
- I knew that was coming
when you said “I got one more”
and you started smirking.
Man—
- Slytherin?
- Lattimore going in, uh,
Slytherin, man. Yeah.
- Slytherin, man. He going to Slytherin, man.
You know, I'mma, you know,
I don't want to hold you too long, man.
I got one more,
I got one more little segment
I want to do with
you, man. You know, I know you want to
celebrate other wide receivers, too.
You know, everybody loves Mike Evans, man.
And, you know, we in a day and age where,
you know, people don't get their flowers
and people don't share love and, like,
all th—you know, that's
honestly why I had the pass-rush summit.
I wanted to, like, spread the
love to, like, younger players
that don't get to experience, like,
the Pro Bowl, and they don't get to do some
of the things that these other guys do.
Even though that they're, like, successful
and they rush their ass off
and they're, like, great players,
they don't get to go to the pass—
they don't get to go to
the Pro Bowl.
So, I wanted to have a pass-rush summit
where we talk about pass
rush on and off the football field
and we could just hang
and I can, it's a place where I can, like,
talk to these guys and tell them, like—
it's not a coaching clinic by any means;
like, I learn something from these guys—
but it's a place for me where I can, like,
you know, show love to these guys
and tell them, like, "Hey, bro, like,
just keep doing this, and
you gonna be this and that.”
Like,
I remember when Maxx Crosby went, bro.
I said, “Maxx, like,
you're such a great player, bro.”
Like—this was, like, way before,
this was, like, way before.
Like, you know, of course he was gonna have success regardless, bro.
- He started ballin', yeah.
- But I was like, “Maxx, like, bro, like,
you got everything that you need, bro.
Like, you gonna be a superstar
in this league one day, bro.
Like, I'm such a huge fan of you, bro.”
And you know, to fast-forward to, like,
I think it was three pass-rush
summits after that,
and he had the floor to talk.
And he was like, “Von,
like, when you told me, like, A, like,
I'mma be a superstar
one day,” he was like,
"Bro, like, that's
when I, like, saw it and felt it, man.”
And for me, like,
that's why I wanted to have the pass-rush
summit, to, like, show
love and, like, create
those type of moments, man.
And if it was other receivers
that you wanted to celebrate,
man, and, you know, it's a lot of younger receivers
out here, man, making impacts,
you know, who would be, like,
your top five current wide receivers other
than Mike Evans?
- Oh, I thought you was
about to ask me, like, underrated
wide receivers.
- Underrated?
It could be underrated.
- My top five? It’s hard. Man, I hate doing a top five
because it's so hard, but, like—
- Do the top five underrated.
- This season?
- Top five underrated.
- I'll do top five current right now.
I’ll do top five current right now.
And then—you said not including myself?
We'll go Davante Adams.
Diggs. J. Jets.
Tyreek Hill.
Ja’Marr Chase.
- Ja'Marr Chase for sure. What about the top
five underrated wide receivers?
- Scary Terry.
Terry McLaurin is the most underrated
receiver in the league, I think.
He's so tough.
Chris Godwin is super underrated.
- He's a beast.
- It's hard.
There's so many guys that are underrated
in the league.
Let's go Gabe Davis.
Gabe Davis is, he’s a really good—
- I love Gabe. Gabe Davis is my boy.
- He’s a really good player, man.
Physical.
High-point the ball. Contested
catch. Run after the catch.
Who else we got?
Is Mike Williams underrated?
I feel like people talk about
Mike Williams a lot, though.
- I think outside of the football world—
- Like, Mike Williams is nice.
- Outside of the football world,
they probably don't talk about him as much.
- Well, we know about him.
- Yeah, we know. I know about Mike.
He was in the division. Yeah, yeah. For sure.
- Mike Williams for the Chargers. He has an injury. He has an ankle
injury right now. But, man, he's—
- He’s a beast.
- his routes are getting better every year.
He's one of the best contested-catch
guys, high-point guys in the league
if not the best high-point guy.
Who else we got? There’s so many other guys.
Justin Watson, Kansas City Chiefs,
my former teammate. He's No. 84.
He's super underrated.
- That’s dope.
- He's having a great season this year.
- Caught a few touchdowns this year. Man, he's
having his best year of his career.
- That’s dope, my boy.
I wanna let you go, but in the chat,
I got two questions for you, my boy.
What's your favorite team to play against?
And this is from,
this is from goat44.
- I say the same every time: a team
that's playing heavy, you know, Cover 1.
Just man coverage with the safety, like,
not tilted toward my side. So, I love teams
that do that. And it's rare to get a team
like that. It’s rare to get teams like that
since, like, 2015.
But, you know, teams
that play me like that, you know, I love that.
So, Cover 1 teams that play a lot of man.
- I like playing against Tom Brady...
cuz Tom and the other great—
- He ain’t gonna scramble.
- No, no. It's not even about scrambling.
It’s just, like, he not really worried about,
like, “Let me load up this side and chip
Von all game.” Like, “Let me motion this tight
end in and crack him.”
Like, he don't do none of that stuff. He’s so—
- Oh, we try. We tried to in the,
in the playoff
game last year. It's just you, A.D.,
Floyd,
y'all was all over the place.
- It was just so—it's just so many...
I felt like, I felt like—whenever
I do play Tom, like, he don't really, like,
focus on me like that.
He's so focused on his game and trying
to be the best quarterback that he can be.
And I kind of just can, I can just play.
And that's
with all the greats. You know? That's
with all the greats.
I don't know, Aaron Rodgers
they was chipping me a little bit, too. Like,
Aaron Rodgers, when we played them this year,
they was whipping me, man.
- You should be getting chipped.
You should be getting chipped, by the way, a lot.
Like, that's smart football. Like, who's not gonna,
you've gotta get some chips, man.
- I just wanna line up anc play football, man.
I just wanna line up and play football, man. But, um-
- You just wanna hurt the quarterback and get sack-fumbles
and get sacks.
- I don't, I don't. I go for the ball every time.
- You can't do that all day.
I go for the ball every time. I'm not trying to...,
They're the premier players in our league.
- You're gonna hurt their arm or something.
Like, you gotta, like, you're one of the best
edge-rushers in history, bro.
You've gotta get chipped.
- Bruh, you say you like going against Cover 1,
I like going against the greats.
- Hopefully we play y'all in the Super Bowl.
- I hope-
- Bro, we game-plan against you. You know that, right?
We try to chip you. With Tom at quarterback,
no matter who it is. [Laughing]
- I got one more question, man, and then I'm gonna let you go, man.
I appreciate you, bro.
What is the worst weather
that you've ever played in?
This is from Asia Brown.
- Yeah,
we played Baltimore in 2018.
I think it was Lamar Jackson's
rookie year. Man, it was like 30 degrees,
but it was pouring down raining, and it was-
- So it wasn't snowing yet.
- The ball felt like a brick,
nah, it wasn't snow, it was just rain.
I think both teams combined
had like 15, 20 drops
in one game.
I'll say, I'll say like 10 to 15.
But the ball was like a brick.
It was super slick, tough game.
And Lamar Jackson went off on us
too that game,
by the way. He's a rookie, making real good
plays in the rain and cold.
- Just scrambling,
my boy.
Um, you know, kstidge said:
I knew I loved Mike Evans,
but he loves Harry Potter, and he's now
my favorite receiver of all time.
That's kstidge?
- My man.
- That's love.
This is my guy, Mike Evans, man. Ay, my Aggie
brother, man, my brother in real life.
Man, I appreciate you taking time
out of your day.
I know the family's well.
You've got a beautiful family,
but I just wanted to send blessings
to all of y'all, man.
It's an honor and a privilege to do this
Voncast with you and to talk to you on
on your off day,
man. It's all love and respect.
If you ever need me for anything, man,
if you just want me to come to
when your daughter grows up
and you want me to come dance
at the wedding, man.
I'll come dance at the wedding, man.
Whatever you want me to do, man.
I'm forever in debt to you, my boy.
I love you, man.
And I appreciate you, man.
And I wish you the very best.
And we'll see you in the Super Bowl, my boy.
- I like the sound of that, man.
I appreciate you, bro.
Thanks for having me.
And I still remember you
throwing up at 5:45 workouts
during the NFL lockout my freshman year.
That was cool, man. You was out there getting it.
- Bruh, I was trying to come and still like,
'cause it ain't nothing
like working out in college, bro.
You know, like,
you don't really work like that.
- Oh, you can't beat them workouts.
- Oh, man.
Well, I was trying to come back and,
you know, work out with Tony and Cyrus,
you know, still be a part of, like,
Texas A&M, but them boys was getting it.
I ain't ran like that since then. [Laughing]
Hey, love, man.
I appreciate you, my boy.
- All right, big bro.
- Yes, sir.
Much success, bro.
In conclusion of
this week's Voncast, um,
we got some questions for me.
It says,
"Hey, GM Von, any update on OBJ?"
Um...bruh, OBJ,
he's going around, he's
doing what he do, man.
It's like he's getting recruited again.
You know, you got to show love.
But I tell you what, like,
you know,
you can't really listen to all the
the announcements, and
what's his name?
Adam Schefter.
Of course,
they have valuable knowledge,
but it's not over 'till it's over.
That's all I can say about that. It's
not over.
We don't know where OBJ going
until we find out where OBJ going.
I know they said the Cowboys
and the Giants,
and this and that.
You just got to wait and see, man.
That's all I'mma say about that.
I don't want to,
you know, create any headlines.
I think it's already a lot of headlines.
You know, we just have to wait and see.
You know, he said he was going to sign at
the beginning of December, right in there.
So you guys just have to wait and see.
I want to spill no tea, nothing like that.
Let him go see the Cowboys.
Let him go see the Giants.
But wait 'till he sees
Bills Mafia
and what we're doing here in Buffalo, man,
I think he's going to be blown away.
This week's title song?
I think last week was,
last week was powder.
Just normal powder.
Last week's song was just powder.
And this week's title song will have to be
making music in Motown.
Making music in Motown, for sure.
Oh, they wanna know about Detroit? OK.
First and foremost,
the Detroit Lions have a tough team.
And it's led by Dan Campbell.
He's an Aggie, too.
This week is going to be a
hornet's nest,
and we got to find a way
to beat the hornets in that game.
They've got a team full of tough guys.
I got a lot of respect
for Jamaal Williams,
a lot of respect for this offensive line.
Decker and Sewell. I love Jared Goff.
He's one of my favorite quarterbacks.
He's one of my favorite quarterbacks out.
This defense is stacked.
Jeffrey Okudah,
very, very talented QB,
I mean, cornerback.
And he's from Dallas, one of my boys.
And yeah, it's going to be, it's
going to be a hard-fought game,
just like all of the games
that they've been on.
And they, they're on a three-game
win streak, and they beat the, um,
they had,
they beat the New York Giants.
And they're a really good team as well.
So, you know, you can go up there
and beat the Giants, man.
We've gotta, we've gotta be on our P's and Q's
at Ford Stadium this week.
Man, on Thanksgiving,
everybody's going to be watching, man.
It's going to be a tough game,
I already know, man.
And um...you know, this week,
playing the Detroit Lions on Thanksgiving,
I just want to dedicate this game
to Bills Mafia, the city of Orchard Park
and the city of Buffalo
and Western New York, man, for,
you know, really helping us out.
A football team.
Like, you guys came out and dug us out
and did all this extra stuff
and brought us your plowers.
And, you know, just to hear the stories
of some of my teammates,
like one of my teammates
woke up the next morning,
he heard like an engine outside,
and he looked outside, and it was
the neighbors had all gathered
around to like dig him out. Like,
nobody had asked them to do it
or anything like that.
They just knew, like,
he plays for the Buffalo Bills
and he has to get out
because he has to travel to Detroit.
And it just shows you
the type of community that we have
and, you know, how much they love
the game of football here.
So, you know,
if I could give all of you guys game balls,
like, we will.
We gotta figure out a way to do that.
We're gonna give everybody that helped,
you know, all of my teammates
and everybody out.
We gonna figure a way
to get those guys game balls.
And we're gonna dedicate this game
on Thanksgiving
to the city of Orchard Park, Buffalo
and western New York.
And we're gonna dedicate this game
to Bills Mafia.
I really appreciate you guys, man,
for tuning in to this week's Voncast.
I'm Von Miller,
and I'm out.